WE HAVE MEMBERS AT VARIOUS.
COMMITTEES PRESENTING BILLS ARE
SITTING ON A OTHER COMMITTEES
AND WE ONLY HAVE ONE MEASURE
BEFORE TODAY AND IT'S A V.. SIX
FORTY TWO BY SOME WOMAN WOMAN
LEMOND SO IT YOU'RE READY -- YOU
MAY PRESENT YOUR MEASURE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS UNDER
EXISTING LAW THE DEFINITION OF
BROKER IS VERY VAGUE AND
CIRCULAR LEADING TO THE
CONFUSION FROM LENDERS ABOUT
WHICH ENTITIES.
THEY CAN PARTNER WITH WHEN
ARRANGING LOANS THE DEFINITION
OF BROKER AN EXISTING LAW WAS
FORMULATED LONG BEFORE THE RISE
OF THE INTERNET AND THE
EVOLUTION OF ONLINE LEAD
GENERATION.
SO OUR LAW NEEDS TO BE UPDATED
WITH THIS ONLINE ACTIVITY IN
MIND THIS BILL WILL ALLOW.
ONLINE LENDERS TO GENERATE
ONLINE LEAD GENERATORS TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA SIMPLY THIS BILL
REQUIRES THREE BASIC THINGS FROM
THE COMPANY'S ONE GET A BUSINESS
LICENSE FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT.
TO PROVIDE TRANSPARENT AS
CLOSURES TO YOUR CUSTOMERS AND
THREE OBTAIN YOUR CUSTOMER'S
CONSENT BEFORE SELLING AND
TRANSMITTING THEIR CONFIDENTIAL
DATA.
I WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
LENDERS AND LEE GENERATORS OVER
THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
ENSURE THAT THIS BILL
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSES THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION CONCERNS AND
OUR LENDING MARKETS WITHOUT
PLACING.
UNNECESSARY BURDENS ON THE
BUSINESSES THAT WORK IN THIS
AREA TO LAST YEAR'S PROCESS IT I
WAS ABLE TO GET A LARGE NUMBER
OF CONSUMER AND COMMERCIAL
LENDERS AND BROKERS COMFORTABLE
WITH THIS APPROACH.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER PROVIDING HELP
WITH AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS A
NUMBER OF THE ISSUES RAISED BY
THE OPPONENTS.
IN YOUR FOLDERS YOU SHOULD HAVE
A COPY OF THE AUTHOR'S
AMENDMENTS BASED ON THE
SUGGESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THOSE AMENDMENTS RESPOND TO ALL
OF THE CONCERNS LISTED IN THE
SMALL BUSINESS FINANCE FINANCE
ASSOCIATION LETTER IN ADDITION
TO ADDRESSING A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE ONLINE
LENDERS ALLIANCE.
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW I HAVE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
TO MAKESURE THAT THE
PROTECTIONS IN THIS BILL.
CAN APPROPRIATELY IN FORCE BEING
FORCED BY THE REGULATOR.
BASED ON THAT ADVICE AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM THE D.
B. O. THERE ARE TWO PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT I COULD NOT
ACCEPT BECAUSE I BELIEVE THEY
UNDERMINE THE REGULAR THE
REGULATORS ABILITY TO ENFORCE
THE LAW.
OPPONENTS LIKELY WILL LIBRARY ON
THOSE TWO POINTS IN THE HEARING
TODAY I AM HAPPY TO RESPOND AND
ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
ABOUT THOSE.
BUT IN SUMMARY BOTH OF THOSE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WOULD LIKELY
PUT THIS BILL AND PRETTY IN THE
EVENT THAT THIS BILL MAKES IT TO
THE GOVERNOR.
I HAVE HAD AN OPEN DELIVERED A
PROCESS IN TRYING TO GET THIS
BILL TO THE RIGHT PLACE AS SHOWN
BY THE TENS -- THE TEN SETS OF
AMENDMENTS THAT I HAVE TAKEN IN
RESPONSE TO THE CONCERNS VOICED
BY THE INDUSTRY AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE STAFF.
SINCE LAST YEAR.
AS SHOWN IN THE HAND OUT IN.
FRONT OF YOU WHICH I THINK IS
GOING TO BE PASSED AROUND --
THERE WE HAVE A REMOVE
SIGNIFICANT OPPOSITION FROM THIS
BILLING ADDRESS NUMEROUS CONCERN
FROM THE INDUSTRY I WISH WE
COULD HAVE FOUND A RESOLUTION TO
EVERYONE'S CONCERNED BUT I FIND
MYSELF IN THE POSITION OF HAVING
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THE POSITION
OF OUR STATE REGULATOR IN THE
POSITION OF THE TWO GROUPS.%
IN OPPOSITION BASED ON MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH DB O.
CONSUMER GROUPS LENDERS AND
BROKERS I KNOW THAT THIS BILL
WILL GO A LONG WAY IN CLARIFYING
WHAT HAS BEEN A CONFUSING
SECTION OF OUR STATE LENDING
LAWS.
I HOPE THAT WE CAN MOVE THIS
EFFORT FORWARD AND NOT LET
ARGUMENTS BY THE OPPONENT SINK
THIS LONG EFFORT.
ME TODAY I DO HAVE A SUPPORT.
FOR THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL CANDLE
KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION CLICK -- AS STATED BY
THE UTHOR ONLINE LENDING IS THE
FASTEST GROWING CHANNEL WHERE
CONSUMERS FALL INTO HIGH COST
LOANS WITH TRIPLE DIGIT INTEREST
RATES ONLINE LENDERS.
ARE HEAVILY RELIANT ON THE
GENERATORS TO GATHER CONSUMERS
FINANCIAL INFORMATION.
AND FUNNEL THAT DATA BACK TO
LENDERS WHO BID AGAINST EACH
OTHER FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SELL THE CONSUMER ALONE.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA LAW IS
UNCLEAR ON HOW THESE ONLINE LEAD
GENERATORS ARE REGULATED.
THIS BILL IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION -- AND IT MAKES CLEAR
THAT THESE COMPANIES NEED TO
LICENSE AN OVERSIGHT FROM OUR
STATE'S FINANCIAL REGULATOR.
WHILE WORKING WHILE OUR
ORGANIZATION CONTINUES TO FIGHT
FOR STRONGER CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS INCLUDING AN
INTEREST RATE CAP ON THESE LANDS.
THIS BILL WILL PUT A STOP TO
THESE COMPANIES OPERATING IN THE
SHADOWS AND FAILING TO TELL
CONSUMERS HOW THEY ARE USING
THEIR CONFIDENTIAL DATA.
WE SUPPORT THIS REASONABLE
APPROACH ME OR DRIVER THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE QUICKNESS AND
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
CHRIS MORROW BEHALF OF ON DECK --
CAPITAL WHICH IS THE LARGEST
ONLINE SMALL BUSINESS LENDING
PLATFORM UNITED STATES AND USES
TECHNOLOGY TO EXPAND ACCESS. TO
CAPITAL FOR SMALL BUSINESSES ON
DECK BELIEVES A SICK BABY SIX
FORTY TWO WILL PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED CLARITY ON THE TREATMENT
OF DIFFERENT WRITTEN REFERRAL
RELATIONSHIPS UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA FINANCING LAW.
WHICH HAS CREATED UNCERTAINTY
FOR COMMERCIAL LENDERS AND OUR
BUSINESS PARTNERS REGARDING WHAT
ACTIVITIES ARE PERMISSIBLE AND
ARE SUBJECT TO THE LICENSURE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE CFL IS FAILED TO KEEP PACE
WITH TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATIONS
IN ONLINE MARKETING REFERRAL IN
BROKERING ACTIVITIES EXISTING
CERTAIN UNCERTAINTY AS TO HOW TO
APPLY THE CFL THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND ACTIVITIES.
HAS CREATED TRAPS FOR ON WHERE
RECEIVE ALL LICENSEES WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME AS MADE CFL
LICENSURE LESS ATTRACTIVE FOR
PROSPECTIVE LICENSEES.
THE BILL WOULD CLARIFY THE
EXISTING STATUTORY AND AMBIGUITY
BY EXPRESSLY DEFINING.
BROKERING ACTIVITY A BY SETTING
CLEAR STANDARDS FOR MARKETING
AND REFERRAL PROGRAMS THE BILL
ALSO RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANT
DIFFERENCES AMONG CONVENTIONAL
BROKERING ACTIVITIES WERE THE
BROKER ACTIVELY MANAGES A
CUSTOMER RELATIONSHIP.
REFER OR ACTIVITIES WHERE THE
BROKEN THE LENDER EXCHANGE
CONFIDENTIAL CUSTOMER DATA AND
PASS A PERIPHERAL ACTIVITIES
WERE THE REFERRAL PARTNER SIMPLY
PROVIDES MARKETING INFORMATION
TO POTENTIAL BORROWERS.
ALONG WITH A LINK TO THE
LENDER'S WEBSITE THESE
ACTIVITIES.
AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT RISKS FOR
SMALL BUSINESS BORROWERS AND ON
THE LEVEL OF REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT SHOULD ALSO BE
CALIBRATED. TO MASS THOSE RISKS
ON DECK SUPPORTS THE TAILORED
REGULATORY APPROACH TAKEN IN A
B..
SIX FORTY TWO ACHIEVING THIS
BALANCE IS COMPLICATED GIVEN THE
DIVERSITY OF REFERRAL MODELS
THAT EXIST BUT THE BILL IS A BIG
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION BY
PROVIDING CLEAR DISTINCTIONS
AMONG BROKERING A REFERRAL
ACTIVITIES.
AND ALLOWING CERTAIN FLEXIBILITY
IN THE COMPENSATION ARRANGEMENTS
PERMITTED THERE UNDER THE BILL
WILL PROVIDE GREATER LEGAL
CERTAINTY CREATE A MORE LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD FOR EXISTING CFL
LICENSEES AND OPEN THE DOOR FOR
MORE COMPANIES TO EXPLORE
LICENSURE.
UNDER THE CFL. FOR THOSE REASONS
ON DECK SUPPORTS A B. SIX FORTY
TWO APPRECIATION LEADERSHIP.
OF A MISSILE MON IN THIS AREA
AND RESPECTFULLY -- URGES IN MY
BOAT.
THANK YOU AND IT DOES SO WITH
THIS IN SUPPORT EMILY PAPPAS ON
BEHALF OF LENDING TREE WE SWITCH
TO A SUPPORT POSITION WE
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR THE
LAST.
SEVERAL MONTHS AND GET INTO A
PLACE WHERE WE CAN SUPPORT.
FUTURE MEMBERS MIKE MONEGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT SINGER NINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THE GAP TO PRINCIPAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION
.
HI BABY CANTON WITH THE ONLINE
LENDERS ALLIANCE AND MORE IT'S
UNFORTUNATE TO SAY BUT WE
CONTINUE TO BE VERY STRONGLY
OPPOSED -- WE JUST FIND THAT
WE'RE HERE TWO YEARS LATER IN
THE SAME POSITION THAT WE WERE --
LAST YEAR ARE I'M SORRY ONE YEAR
LATER WHERE WE WERE LAST YEAR
WHEN THIS BILL AT THIRTY TWO OH
SEVEN WITH THE EXACT SAME ISSUES
THAT WE HAD CONCERNS ABOUT -- WE
HAVE MET WITH THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF NUMEROUS TIMES WE'VE MET
WITH DB O. NUMEROUS TIMES WHAT
WE FIND -- INTERESTING IS THAT
WE JUST HAD MEETINGS WITH THE
VIDEO AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OVER THE PAST. TWO WEEKS AND
THEY HAVE TOLD AS THEY DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL NOW
FOR THERE IS THERE SOMEONE ELSE
SAYING THAT THAT'S FINE BUT IN
OUR MEETINGS WE HAVE ASKED WE
HAVE REPEATEDLY ASKED TVO.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO MAKE THIS A
BETTER BILL FOR YOU AND THEY
HAVE REPEATEDLY TOLD US WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL?
SO WE FEEL FRUSTRATED AT THAT
THAT WE CAN'T GET AN ANSWER FROM
D. B. O. WHEN WE ARE CONTINUALLY
TOLD.
LET US TO STOP SO COMMONPLACE.
MANCHESTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR BRADFORD PRESENT.
CHANG CHANG HERE COMING OUT OF
DELHI.
BROWSER.
BROWSER HERE WEST SO.
SO HERE POURTANT TINA. FOR THIS
QUESTION I'M SORRY TO CONTINUE
TO SMOKE YEAH WHEN WE ARE
CONTINUALLY TOLD THAT OUR
AMENDMENTS CANNOT BE ACCEPTED --
BECAUSE IF THE VIOS --
OBJECTIONS SO WE DECIDED TO GO
TO THE B. O. THEMSELVES AND
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE TODAY WEEK
WE HAVE THE SAME TWO PRIMARY
ISSUES WHICH ARE THE TIMING OF
THE DISCLOSURES.
AND WHO IS REQUIRED TO GIVE
CONSENT WE BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
PROVIDED NUMEROUS ITERATIONS OF
LANGUAGE WHICH WOULD GET THE
AUTHOR TO WHERE SHE WANTS TO BE
TO PROVIDE WITH ME IN A WHAT IS
BEING PORTRAYED AS CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
BUT WILL ALSO COMPORT WITH THE
BEHAVIOR OF THE CONSUMER ON
THESE PLATFORMS -- THE LANGUAGE
AS IT IS NOW IN THE BILL DOES
NOT COMPORT WITH CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR AND IT'S GOING TO LEAD
TO CONSUMERS GOING TO OTHER
SITES.
SO -- UNTIL WE CAN HAVE THOSE
TWO ISSUES TAKEN CARE OF WE WILL
CONTINUE OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
THE CHAIRMAN.
AND SENATOR SO I I DON'T WANT TO
BE IN A POSITION TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL BUT THAT IS THE POSITION
THAT WERE AND AND IT'S NOT
BECAUSE WE WANT TO HIDE IN THE
SHADOWS.
MY COMPANY WITH TWO COMPANIES
ONE IS A LEAD GENERATOR PER SE
AS THIS BILL DESCRIBES IT
CALIFORNIA BASED.
AND THE OTHER COMPANY HAS A CFL
ON DETAIL LICENSE SO WE ARE OUT
FRONT WE MEET WITH THE C. F.
CFPB FTC.
AND THE TV -- REGULARLY WE ARE
NOT IN THE SHADOWS.
WE HAVE BEEN PROMOTING THIS
LEGISLATION AND THE CONCEPT OF
THIS LEGISLATION FOR SEVERAL
YEARS BEFORE LAST YEAR'S A. B.
THIRTY TWO OH SEVEN WE WERE OUT
FRONT SAYING WE NEED SOME
REGULATION BECAUSE THE BROKER
DEFINITION IS MESSED UP.
BUT THE THE PROBLEM THAT WE FACE
IS LEAD JEN SOUNDS SIMPLE ON THE
SURFACE IT'S A VERY COMPLEX VERY
LAYERED.
ACTIVITY.
AND THE LEAD GENS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE THAT PEOPLE
IN THIS ROOM ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
DEAL WITH.
PRIMARILY SUBPRIME CONSUMERS.
NOW HERE'S WHERE IS THE POSITION
WE'VE BEEN WE'VE BEEN PUT IN.
THIS IS SUCH A COMPLICATED
INDUSTRY THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
REGULATE THE INDUSTRY AND
PROTECT CONSUMERS IS STATE TO
REGULATE THE LEAD AGGREGATORS.
WHO HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
LANDERS?
THERE'S NOT THAT MANY LEAD
AGGREGATORS OUT THERE.
WE HAVE STEPPED UP AND SAID
GUESS WHAT WE CAN HELP WHY CAN'T
YOU REGULATE THE REST OF THE
INDUSTRY BECAUSE THERE'S TENS OF
THOUSANDS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PUBLISHERS ALL OVER THE WORLD.
YOU CAN'T DO IT SO WE HAVE TAKEN
A POSITION TO SAY GUESS WHAT USE
US.
USE US TO PROTECT CONSUMERS TO
PROTECT THE GOOD SIDE OF THE
INDUSTRY WE WILL TAKE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND WE'VE ACCEPTED A LOT OF THAT
IN GENERATIONS OF THIS BILL BUT
WE HAVE ALSO ASKED.
THE AUTHOR OF MULTIPLE TIMES LET
US WORK THE WAY WE NEED TO WORK
WE CAN ACHIEVE THE THREE
OBJECTIVES.
THAT IS THE ONLY WOMAN LET ALONE
STATED IN HER OPENING AND IN
FACT ON JUNE ELEVENTH I SENT THE
DB O. AND HER OFFICE A
DESCRIPTION OF EACH OBJECTIVE
THAT SHE LAID OUT.
AND HOW WE CAN FULFILL THOSE
OBJECTIVES WITH PROPER LANGUAGE
NOT TAKING ANYTHING AWAY FROM
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
JUST SAYING WE CAN MEET THESE
OBJECTIVES THIS COMES DOWN TO A
TECHNICAL ISSUE THAT MAKES OUR
JOB IMPOSSIBLE AND WHEN OUR JOB
IS IMPOSSIBLE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE GOOD GUYS THAT ARE NOT
HIDING IN THE SHADOWS.
ARE GONNA BE FORCED OUT OF THE
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA OR WE'RE
GOING TO BE AT SUCH A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE THAT WE
CAN'T HELP PROTECT CONSUMERS AND
THIS IS NOT ANECDOTAL.
SO ON MARCH EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN US NEWS AND WORLD
REPORT.
A PUBLISHED AN ARTICLE THAT SAID
SIX THE SCAMS THAT INVADE YOUR
BANK ACCOUNT NUMBER FOUR WAS
ONLINE LENDING SCAMS.
THERE ARE SOPHISTICATED TALENTED
CRIMINAL ACTORS OUT THERE WHO DO
CONSUMERS ALL THE TIME.
IT HAPPENS NOW IF YOU TAKE A
COMPANY LIKE MINE AND SAY.
YOU CAN'T FUNCTION COMPETITIVELY
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT.
THEN WE ARE THAT WE ARE THE BEST
AIR BAG OR THE SEAT BELT THE
PROTECTION THE SHIELD FOR
CONSUMERS.
IF YOU TAKE US OUT OF THE
EQUATION SO YOU CAN'T BE
COMPETITIVE GUESS WHAT HAPPENS
TO THE BAD GUYS THEN HE DON'T
CARE.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO REGISTER
OR GET A LICENSE FROM THE T. V. --
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO FOLLOW THE
RULES THEY DON'T FOLLOW THEM
ALREADY.
SOME MIGHT PLEAD FOR TWO YEARS
HAS BEEN TO THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
AND EVERYBODY INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS.
PLEASE LET US FUNCTION IN A WAY
THAT WE CAN DO BUSINESS THAT WE
CAN PROTECT THE CONSUMERS JUST
DON'T PUSH US OUT WITH THE
LEGISLATION BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T.
PROTECT ANYONE AND WE HAVE
PROPOSED MULTIPLE WAYS OF DOING
IT THEY DO NOT TAKE AWAY
ANYTHING FROM WHAT.
THE CHAIRWOMAN ONCE AND THOSE
HAVE BEEN REJECTED OUTRIGHT MY
JUNE ELEVENTH EMAIL EXPLAINING
HOW WE MEET ALL THREE OF THOSE
OBJECTIVES.
NO REPLY FROM THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE NO REPLY FROM THE DEAL.
WHAT DO WE DO WE WANT TO BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION THIS DOESN'T?
GET THERE UNFORTUNATELY SO WE
ARE IN A POSITION TO TO HAVE TO
OPPOSE IT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MELANIE
CUEVAS WITH CAN TANA WATSON
HEARD MEN ON BEHALFOF THE TRIBE
OF UPPER LAKE UNFORTUNATELY
STILL IN OPPOSITION WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S REMOVAL
OF THE ORIGINAL TRIBAL LANGUAGE
WHICH WE FOUND TO BE -- I'M
CLEAR AND VERY PROBLEMATIC WERE
VERY DISHEARTENED TO SEE THAT
SHE REJECTED THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS -- WHICH WE SUPPORTED
ON ONE OF REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION.
CLEAR FINDING WHICH ABOUT TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY IS ESSENTIAL FOR OUR
BUSINESS FOR OUR TRIBAL MEMBERS
AND FOR SURROUNDING COMMUNITY
THANK YOU THE QUICKNESS.
AS A MATTER NOT WHAT HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF TUNICA
BLOCKS YOU TRIBE I'D LIKE TO
LINE MY COMMENTS WITH THAT THE
SPEAKER HAD OF ME WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD COULD
ANI REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
FINANCIAL SERVICE PROVIDERS
ASSOCIATION WE WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
THE QUICKNESS OUTSELLING
REPRESENTING THE SMALL BUSINESS
MINUS THE STATION JUST WANT TO
THANK THE THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF FOR WORKING ON THE FOUR
ISSUES THAT WE RAISED IN OUR
LETTER.
MY CLIENT IS STILL REVIEWING THE
LANGUAGE OF WE RECEIVED
YESTERDAY AND JUST GOING THROUGH
IT BUT JUST FROM OUR INITIAL
REDUCING DAVE DRESS ALL THE
CONCERNS THAT WOULD RAISE THE
LETTER -- I CAN'T CHANGE OUR
POSITION RIGHT NOW BUT TO PEERS
THAT -- THAT IT DID THEY DID
ADDRESS ALL OF THEM THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAUL BAUER ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMERCIAL FINANCE COALITION --
WE TOO IN A SIMILAR POSITION TO
ALEX'S.
WERE REVIEWING THE THE
AMENDMENTS -- WE BELIEVE THAT
MORE CHANGES ARE IN ORDER AND IF
THE BILL MOVES ALONG YOU KNOW
WHEN.
WE TALK TO THE AUTHOR ABOUT THEM --
BUT AT THIS TIME WE WE STILL ARE
POST THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION SOON HEARING ON ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
CENTER WORKS OF LITERATURE.
ARE THERE MEET MEN SORT OF BEEN
AGREED TO NO.
THERE WERE THE BIG YOU REFERENCE
AMENDMENTS AND THERE THE AUTHORS
OF MOMENTS SENT TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
WELL -- I SUPPORT THIS BILL LAST
YEAR AND I ALSO AGREE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL EARLIER IN THE YEAR.
AND THERE BEEN SOME -- CONCERNS
RAISED -- ABOUT.
I THINK THERE ARE ARGUMENTS THIS
BILL CREATES.
SOME CHALLENGES.
TO FEDERAL SOVEREIGNTY LAWS AND
THAT CONCERNS ME VERY MUCH THAT
PART OF THE BILL IF I WOULD I
WOULD JUST HIGHLY RECOMMEND THAT
YOU TRY TO ADDRESS THAT.
IN PARTICULAR THAT THIS MIGHT
SET A BAD PRECEDENT TO KIND OF
GET THE STATE INVOLVED IN
SOVEREIGNTY ISSUES.
WHICH IS NOT AN AREA I THINK WE
SHOULD BE -- GOING INTO IF NOT --
SUPPORTING THAT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE -- THERE ARE ARE.
TRIBES THAT HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY
ELIMINATED.
FROM -- FROM THE FACE OF THE
EARTH THROUGH.
GENOCIDE AND AND AND IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND I CAN'T THINK OF A OF A OF A
PROTECTED GROUP IN OUR IN OUR
COUNTRY THAT HAS BEEN WRONG MORE
THAN THE TRIBES.
CURRENTLY THE HIGHEST HIGH
SCHOOL DROPOUT RATES THE HIGHEST.
POVERTY RATES IN THE COUNTRY AND
IN OUR STATE.
THE LOWEST COLLEGE ATTAINMENT
RATES -- JUST A THE THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGES OF PEOPLE IN POVERTY
WITH AN A A DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP
ARE IN THE NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATION.
AND THEY'RE STILL A LOT THAT WE
NEED TO DO TO CORRECT CORRECT.
THE WRONGS OF HISTORY AND THAT
CONSUMERS TURNS ME ON THIS BILL --
ALL SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY BUT
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN WORK TO
RESOLVE.
THAT IN PARTICULAR AND AND THANK
YOU FOR CONTINUING TO WORK IN
THIS AREA.
THANK YOU AND I WILL SAY THAT
THE SO THE LANGUAGE THAT IS IN
THE CURRENT BILL -- THAT'S THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE RECEIVED
DIRECTLY FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE LAST YEAR AND SO WHAT YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU IS IT D. E.
AMEND THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
THAT PROPOSED TO JUST DELETE IT
ALL TOGETHER.
ON WHAT WE'VE ADVISED THE TRIBES
IS IF THEY WANT LANGUAGE IN
THERE TO COME TO AGREEMENT WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON WHAT
THAT LANGUAGE WOULD BE AND WE
ONCE THERE IS AGREEMENT WE WOULD
GLADLY PUT IT IN THERE.
IN THE MEANTIME THE AMENDMENTS --
IN FRONT OF YOU DO DELETE IT
COMPLETELY.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR CENTER COPY OUR
FOLLOW UP ON THAT IS THAT THE IT
IT'S DELETED BECAUSE THAT'S A
LANGUAGE THEY OBJECTED.
TO RIGHT OKAY.
AND WE WE WILL PUT.
WHATEVER LANGUAGE THEY AGREE
UPON WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
SO THE LANGUAGE WAS GIVEN TO US
DIRECTLY FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE LAST YEAR I THINK WHAT
WAS MENTION IS THE CONFUSION OFF
WITH THE D. B. O. THE DB A WAS
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL LAST
YEAR AS YOU ALL.
PROBABLY KNOW THERE'S BEEN SOME
TRANSITION IN THE APPOINTMENT OF
THE DVL AND SO THE IT IS CORRECT
THEY DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON
ON THIS BILL.
AT LAST YOU THEY WERE TESTIFYING
WITH THIS AND BUT WE'VE
CONTINUED TO USE THE D. B. O. S.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN MOVING
THIS FORWARD.
GREAT. TWO SECONDS WELL KNOWN
GERMAN I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THE SHEPHERD AND
HAS STATED VISOR WAY SO WHY IN
THIS COMMITTEE SUPPORTED.
AB AT THIRTY TWO OH SEVEN LAST
YEAR OF BILL THAT YOU MAKE
COMMITMENTS TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS MOVING FORWARD AND A
PREPARATIONS UNFORTUNATELY THOSE
ISSUES WERE RESOLVED LAST YEAR.
WHEN HE GOT TO APPROPRIATIONS
AND I BELIEVE THE BILL -- WAS
HEALED -- FOR THOSE REASONS AND
MAYBE SOME OTHER ONCE AGAIN
WE'RE HERE A YEAR LATER AND IT'S
THE SAME MEASURE BEFORE US THAT
WE DEALT WITH.
BEFORE IN THE SAME TWO ISSUES
ARE STILL OUTSTANDING THE TIMING
OF PROVIDING CONSUMER DISCLOSURE
INFORMATION AND CLARIFYING THE
BILLS APPLICATION TO TRIBES AND
DESPITE THE DILUTION THERE I
STILL DON'T BELIEVE BASED ON THE
TESTIMONY WE'VE HEARD TODAY AN
OPPOSITION THAT IT IS TRUST.
THE TRIBAL CONCERNS -- THIS
COMMITTEE ALSO ONCE AGAIN
OFFERED UP TWO SETS OF
AMENDMENTS THAT HE RESPECTIVELY --
REJECTED AND I RESPECT THAT AND
NO ANIMOSITY THERE BUT BEING THE
CASE I CAN'T SUPPORT TO MEASURE
THE DAY I HAVE NO RECOMMENDATION
FOR YOUR BILL -- WITHOUT THOSE
TWO RECOMMENDATIONS THAT AGAIN
WERE MADE A LAST YEAR -- BY THIS
COMMITTEE AND WAS SUPPORTED BY
THIS COMMITTEE AND ALLOWING YOUR
BUILD A MOVE FOR LAST YEAR SO.
THAT'S WHERE I AM AS IT STATES
TODAY IF -- MEMBERS ARE INCLINED
TO MAKE A MOTION FOR THIS BILL I
KNOW WHICH BACKED OUT BUT I WILL
NOT BE VOTING FOR THE MEASURE
TODAY.
AND I JUST WANT TO COMMENT ON
THAT I APPRECIATE A WE BUT
EVERYBODY HAS IN FRONT OF THEM
ARE.
THERE ARE TEN SETS OF AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'VE TAKEN SINCE LAST YEAR --
ALL OF THEM HAVE INSISTS THERE I
THINK THE POSITION FOR ME AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL IS DO I TAKE
THE THE FINAL.
TWO OUR ISSUES THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH THE DISCLOSURES AND WHO
PROVIDES THE DISCLOSURES -- AND
WE ABSOLUTELY DO NOT HAVE A
RESOLUTION ON THAT AS WELL AS
THE TRIBAL LANGUAGE WHICH THE
AMENDMENTS REMOVE ALTOGETHER IF
SOMEONE WANTS TRIBAL LANGUAGE IN
THERE I THINK THAT THERE'S A WAY
TO GET TO THOSE THINGS -- IF
THERE IS AGREEMENT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THAT THAT'S
THE LANGUAGE THEY WANT TO SEE
THEIR SO I THINK IT'S BEEN A
IT'S BEEN.
CERTAINLY THE TWO AMENDMENTS
THAT I DID NOT AGREE TO A YOU
KNOW AS IT'S BEEN STATED ALSO
THE ONES THAT ARE HIGHLIGHTED
OUR AMENDMENTS THAT I'VE TAKEN
SPECIFICALLY FOR BY THIS
COMMITTEE.
THAT HAVE REQUESTED ME THAT HAVE
REQUESTED OF THE OF ME OF THIS
BILL -- SO THOSE ARE THE DATES
THEY TOOK A AMENDMENTS FROM THIS
COMMITTEE IS DO I TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS KNOWING THAT THAT IS
NOT.
GOING YOU KNOW.
THAT DESPITE.
DESPITE EVERYONE'S INTEREST IN
WANTING TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT A
SOLUTION TO THIS -- THE THERE IS
CONCERN -- AND THEY WOULD LIKELY
PUT THE POSITION IN A BILL OF
NOT GETTING SIGNED IN THE FUTURE
SO I I THINK THAT THAT'S A HARD.
ONE AND THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS
THAT I HAVE.
IN FRONT OF ME AND IT'S NOT THAT
IS NOT I MEAN IF WE CAN FIND
AGREEMENT I WOULD HAVE FOUND
AGREEMENT WE'VE BEEN TRYING FOR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND CERTAINLY --
IF THIS BILL DOESN'T MOVE
FORWARD WILL BE BACK AT IT NEXT
YEAR -- AS WELL NO AND WE
RESPECT THAT AND AND I'M ALWAYS
SAY THIS ISSUE THAT I THINK WE
ALL FEEL IT'S VITALLY IMPORTANT
BUT I THINK THERE IS A LITTLE
BIT MORE CONSENSUS THAT WE COULD
GET IT'S BEEN EXPRESSED BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
FLASHER IN IT'S BEEN EXPRESSED
AGAIN -- THIS YEAR IT'S BEEN
EXPRESSED BY THE ADVOCATES AS
WELL AS OPPONENTS THAT THERE IS
A A LITTLE BIT MORE OF A SWEET
SPOT THAT WE CAN REACH ON THIS
MEASURE WE JUST HAVEN'T REACHED
A TODAY SO.
THAT'S WHERE MY POSITION IS BUT
LIKE I SAY I HAVE NO IDEAL YES.
CENTER CAPS ARE.
I APPRECIATE THE THE CHAIR'S
COMMENTS AND AND THE CONCERNS
AND I I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
WORK ON SOMETHING FOR A REALLY
LONG TIME TO GET IT TO A
COMMITTEE AND THEN HAVE SOMEONE
SAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S A TWO YEAR
BILL -- SO -- I'M SENSITIVE TO
THAT THE GENTLEMAN THAT SPOKE I
I'M I APOLOGIZE I MISSED IT.
THE PRESENTATION PRESENTING MY
OWN BILL IN HE ASSEMBLY BUT BUT
MY CONCERN IS.
WITH AN OMINOUS SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY -- I THINK THERE'S A REAL
NEED IN THIS AREA AND SO I I I
REALLY -- APPRECIATE YOU DING
YOU TAKING THE TIME AND ENERGY
TO DO WORK IN THE SPACE.
THE GENTLEMAN WHO SPOKE
INDICATED THAT HE HAD NOT
RECEIVED A RESPONSE BACK IN YEAH.
I DON'T NEED TO GET INTO ALL OF
THAT BUT I THINK IT'S IT IT
WOULD BE REALLY GOOD TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
WITH HIM WHETHER YOU AGREE OR
NOT WITH HIS POSITION AND AT
LEAST GIVE THEM A AM AN ANSWER
SO THAT.
HE CAN HEAR FROM YOU WHAT WHAT
IT IT'S WHAT.
WHAT YOUR POSITION IS ON HIS ON
HIS ON THE FRAMEWORK THAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT SO -- LIKE I SAID
I MISSED A BIG PART OF IT AND I
DO APOLOGIZE BUT IT IS IMPORTANT
THIS IS IT THIS IS PARTICULARLY
SENSITIVE IN IN THE BUSINESS
FROM BECAUSE YOU WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE NOT PUTTING
PEOPLE OUT OF BUSINESS THAT
OTHERWISE ARE DOING.
THE RIGHT THING -- BUT EVERYBODY
SHOULD HAVE TO PLAY BY THE SAME
RULES AND SO -- FOR THAT REASON
I'M I'M WILLING TO SPUR YOU
TODAY.
SENATOR DOURADO -- IT SOUNDS
LIKE.
IT'S CLOSER.
EVEN IF IT'S NOT WHERE IT NEEDS
TO BE A NIGHT I THINK THAT.
HOPEFULLY I HEARD YOU SAY YOU
AGREED TO KEEP WORKING ON THE
ISSUES THAT THE CHAIR HAS.
HAS RAISED ARM ON THE RIBAL
ISSUE OUR WORK DONE.
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY ISSUES FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AND I BELIEVE
THERE'S A WAY TO GET THERE SO.
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE COMMITTED TO
THAT WE WE THE AMOUNT THE
AMENDMENTS IN FRONT OF YOU
DELETED SO THERE IS NO NEED TO
EVEN MENTION IT TO EVEN TALK
ABOUT IT TO EVEN REFERENCE IT.
IT'S DELETED -- AND IF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE TRIBES
FIND THE RIGHT LANGUAGE WILL PUT
IT IN I THINK THAT THIS IS.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT SO IF
THERE IS LANGUAGE THAT IS AGREED
UPON BY OUR GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND THE TRIBES AND WE'LL PUT IT
IN UNTIL THEN WE WON'T MENTION
IT'S COMPLETELY DELETED.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE CONSTRUCTION
SITE -- MANAGER WHICH ARTICLES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BOTH
AGREE.
BEEN MOVED BY CENTERED AROUSAL.
AT I'D SELL RECOMMENDATION FROM
CHAIRS SO IT'S I GUESS.
PUT IN MOTION WOULD BE TO PASS --
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS AS
AMENDED.
SPENCER CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR BRADFORD NO.
NO CHIANG.
KAI ERA.
CARREIRA I DALLY DURAZO.
DRUGS ARE I WAS SO.
WITH SO I YOUR PARTY NOW.
YOUR MAJOR HAS THREE VOTES WILL
LIVE ON CALL
.
MA'AM SECTOR YOU CAN -- LOOK TO
CALL ON I'M SORRY.
THE V..
SIX FORTY TO CALL OUT TO MEMBERS.
CLOSENESS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CHANG.
FOURTEEN NOW I HAVE A QUESTION
HI.
MISTER BRADFORD HOW DID YOU VOTE
VOTING ON THE STRETCHER.
VOTED NO.
BY NOT VOTING
.
WE'LL LOOK TO CALL AGAIN --
RIGHT NOW -- THREE ONE WITH
MISTER POINTY KNOWN NONVOTING
CHAIR VOTING NO.
CALL OUT TO MEMBERS.
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CHANG
[inaudible]
CHANG NOW.
OF THE MEASURE FAILS BECAUSE
SOONER DOLLY WILL NOT BE HERE
WERE WILLING TO GRANT RE
CONSIDERATIONS ROGERS SEEKING
RECONSIDERATION THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR
THE DAY WE STAND ADJOURNED
.
LIKE THEM TO GO.
NO YOU SHAKE YOUR HEAD NO SIR
BUT YOUR WORDS SAY DIFFERENTLY
OKAY AND YOUR POLICIES.
OF THE PAST [inaudible]
SAY DIFFERENTLY.
ALL WE'RE TRYING TO WORK WITH
HERE.
IS A CONSTRUCTIVE PLAN.
THAT IS SAFE FOR EVERYBODY.
LIVE PRAGUE DEVELOPMENT